interview jugement dernier
[Applaudissements]
patrick bruel oui quand tu étais petit
as tu regardé sous le bureau de la
maîtresse pour voir sa culotte
oui mais pas petit un peu plus tard
en troisième professeur d'espagnol au
lycée henri iv voilà j'ai tout dit c'est
le jugement vers nous oblige à patrick
bruel à l'école as tu joué le docteur
avec tes copains
plus avec mes copines avec un ami
espagnol
les affaires françaises
as-tu enfermer des élèves de sexe
féminin dans les cabinets nom bizarre
moi c'est quoi ans bah oui pourquoi tu
aurais pu s'enfermer avec elle mais pour
le pr nisand faire
ensuite on soit tu menti pour devenir
une star non mais il a dit qu'il était
un état ça marche
as-tu renier certains de tes amis n'ont
pas aimé gré tu le vois plus
comme ça
as tu pardonnes été élu n'est
pas toujours quand tu es devenu une star
as-tu profiter de sa notoriété pour
obtenir des avantages particuliers
et voilà on y est
on est en plein dans la rubrique
fellation groupe est allongée
torreton
très exactement ce qu'ils voulaient
éviter il voulait pas répondre si si
j'ai obtenu des avantages particuliers
par le fait d'être connu en effet mais
je n'ai pas spécialement chercher les
objets là tu chantes des chansons
anciennes pour défaire des plus vieilles
tu profiter de la notoriété pour exiger
des pratiques contre nature pas de
préciser charles et jérémy comment tu
parle à dieu
c'est au moins un serveur
toi tu vas perdre camarade
patrick bruel oui c'est il arrivé de
refuser de faire l'amour en prétextant
une migraine oui
arrêté
anigo reinhardt est il arrivé d'absorber
des substances illicites avant de faire
l'amour
nombreux peuples ben non jamais non non
non
non j'ai jamais essayé ça non
est ce que tu te reposes me suis jamais
pendu vient sa pin gouin
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu